okay let's do this one last time so dark
is a show that probably still has you
scratching your head over its ending
though it seemed to be the closing of a
loop that gave the surviving characters
a happy ending
i actually have a new theory that could
paint the final scene out
in a much darker light see what i did
there now throughout this video we'll be
going over why
everything might just be part of an even
bigger loop and the evidence to support
it
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the third season of
the show then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
with all that out the way as always i'm
your host definition
this is the heavy spoiler show now let's
get into our alternate ending theory for
dark
okay so dark centered around adam and
eva two time traveling characters from
separate worlds
that were at war with one another at one
point adam smashed her box in
like you should smash that like button
and eva or rather martha
became pregnant with his child adam
believed that destroying the pair would
end the time loop that all of the
characters in the show had been trapped
in
whereas due to her motherly instinct eva
just wanted to protect her baby
this led to a finale in which adam
killed martha and their son
however much to his surprise he felt
fine after it mr stark
and didn't suddenly disappear now this
is where claudia arrived
and explained that there was actually a
third world that the characters were not
aware of
in this origin world the inventor h.t
tan house
had created a time machine in order to
save his family from dying
however it backfired and split the
universe in two
creating branch realities in which other
possibilities could play out
claudia had spent her time in the loops
retracing all of the family trees of the
characters
and had some eyes that because she could
not fully trace back who the father of a
daughter was
that they were actually in an offshoot
reality rather than the origin one
thus she sent adam and his younger self
jonas
back in time with martha to save
tanhaus's family
and this would then remove the need to
create a time machine
that would create their offshoot worlds
in the first place very
very very very confusing now they
accomplished this
and those not created by the time loop
were seen in the final scene
sitting around a dinner table
celebrating their happy lives
in what the show deemed as paradise it
looked like a crappy friday night to me
but who am i to judge now when i first
saw this
i was over the moon for the characters
they'd finally got their happy ending
and even willa he he got his eye back
now sure some of the characters created
by the family trees in the time loop
were gone but on the whole it was pretty
positive
i was happy to let this go but then
youtube user
viziolod dropped a comment on my ending
explained
that i haven't been able to stop
thinking about they pretty much ruined
the show for me
so thanks a lot they stated that we've
just seen
one more loop being created and after
re-watching the ending with this in mind
i actually think that it holds a lot of
weight so in the final scene we see the
friends sitting around the table
celebrating and all of a sudden the
lights go out
hannah experiences deja vu looks over to
a yellow raincoat
similar to the one that the travelers
wore says that she felt people in the
loops passing away
and states that she will name her child
jonas the entire ending
should be classified as a paradox
however it could
actually indicate that the loop is just
continuing now let's
break this whole scene down just just to
show how this could actually be the case
so firstly the power cuts out now if
this theory is correct
then this power outage is actually
caused by a time machine being operated
tan house has had many regrets in his
life and he was clearly fascinated with
time travel
even before his son's death we know this
because of the argument that the pair
have with one another
and his son pretty much throws his
obsession in his face
this fight becomes the main catalyst
that causes him to run off into the
night
and get into a fatal car crash so i
doubt that his son's return
would have really scratched the itch
that he had especially
since he didn't really know about the
alternate worlds in the first place
who knows his son's statement about
guardian angels saving his life
could have actually made him realize
that time travel was possible
and thus he pushed on even further to
create the machine
thus the power outage that we saw could
be caused by the machine being turned on
and this tearing of realities is what
caused hannah to have her deja vu
now how we can gravitate towards this
theory is because
she looks at the coat and receives the
memories and emotions of those in the
other world
because maybe that world is being
brought into existence at that very
moment
the reason she looks at the co and
recalls the name jonas
is because the memories of another time
loop have come flooding back to her
for a very brief moment whatever happens
she will clearly go on to call her child
jonas who will likely be the same
version that we saw in the show
and everything could start in a new loop
that eventually leads back to this
moment once more
now the other thing to support this
notion is the fact that the worlds
themselves are classed as the triquetra
so when we look at a map of the
realities from the top even with the
third world as part of everything
it still must loop round and interact
with the other two
in order to be part of the one dark has
always moved in motions of three
and whether it's the three timelines
three versions of the characters
three worlds three seasons and so on
everything in these loops of three are
based upon cause and effect
we can clearly see that all of the
worlds themselves are connected
thus this origin world now is still
heavily based upon
the other two as it's required to exist
in order to save tanhaus's son in the
first place
and yet lots of timey why me wibbly
wobbly stuff
so when you look at this scene in a new
context with the aforementioned
information
it does indeed seem like there was a lot
more going on than we initially thought
and this brief moment of the characters
going back into the dark
carries a lot of subtext with it that
ties into the overall show's title and
meaning
the darkness they find themselves in
that once more triggers hannah's deja vu
could indeed be a new cycle that is
started at once more
and this is why the name jonas is
mentioned at the end
purely to tease his return and thus a
new collection of loops
dark has shown us time and time again
that nothing can really be changed
and the only time that it actually
diverted from this notion was
probably in the last half hour of the
final episode in the final season
if this theory is true then it means
that claudia herself was actually part
of the loop and she's just been
traveling around to put everything back
in motion
claudia is therefore really no different
to adam and eve
both of which believe that they are
doing things the way that it should be
done
in order to carry them out the way that
they're always supposed to happen
claudia describes this as quantum
entanglement and not to get to jada
pinkett smith on everyone
but they could have just entered more
entanglements
that caused things to revert back to the
status quo even the origin world itself
exists in a state of flux
with there being alternate realities
tied to it this is because there are
actually two versions of the origin
world
there is the version of the world in
which tanhaus's son dies
and the version in which he doesn't
these two worlds side by
side similar to the two worlds in the
alternate reality show that there are
loops going on
all of the time even if we're not aware
of them though the moves of martha and
jonas
seemingly set things straight they
actually create a paradox
in which they need to exist in order to
save tanhaus's son
which can only be accomplished with the
other worlds and realities
so in conclusion yeah this ending it
might not be as happy as we first
thought
now i have kind of wrestled back and
forth on this as it's a really dark way
to end the show
and it does kind of ruin the fates of a
lot of people leading to a cycle
of never-ending misery in which they get
a couple of years of happiness in the
origin world
before having alternate versions
experience different things
however there is some good news to take
from this i guess
and that there is just a little silver
lining to it
now if this is true then it means that
the characters that we saw missing at
the end
such as charlotte will actually be born
at some point
and they will get to live instead of
simply being wiped out of existence
in the opening of episode 7 tan house
even says that it is possible for
alternate worlds to exist side by side
and this is shown in schrodinger's cat
so we could actually have
two alternate realities existing with
the origin world
unbeknownst to the people in it until
the time machine inevitably brings them
all back together
now dark is deliberately ambiguous for a
number of reasons
and i absolutely love that we as viewers
can revisit it and take
different things from the ending i'm
still yet to see someone completely nail
everything
and i think that there will always exist
this open-ended nature to the show's
finale
and its overall meaning i do think that
this theory does have a lot of weight to
it
and the more i think about it the more
it makes sense and the more it makes
sense
the more i ruin that that nice little
moment for myself
now obviously we will never know for
definite but who knows we could have
just witnessed a completely new loop
starting up once more
without even being aware of it anyway
that's the entire theory
and of course love to hear if you agree
with me or not and it did take a couple
of days to come around to thinking just
how true it might actually be
so if you're unsure then just let it
marinate and come back and let me know
if you noticed anything else that
supports it then drop it below because
i'd love to hear your thoughts
if you want to watch our breakdown of
some of the unanswered questions left at
the end of doc
then make sure you check out our video
at the end which goes over them in full
detail
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
anyway that's the the long long outro
out the way
thank you for sticking with me till the
end i love you take care and whatever
you do
don't bump into your future or past self
much love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you